Kila okay I'm so sorry I have to flex on
you right now in such a severe way the
okay so last night was my my show at the
comedy store and this we'll call her
like an adult actress oh very adorable
like I found her and followed her and
then like you know maybe earlier this
year she followed me back whatever she
was sitting front row at my show she was
so cute she was like kind of
involved and
afterwards she sent me a text that said
and I don't want to assume right I don't
want to assume things but uhuh because
we had just been talking about this she
goes hey I would love to get dinner with
you and Dave sometime and I was like oh
my she has a pregnancy fuming I'm fuming
I was like I can't believe this
just oh all good
George you guys know George stop wasting
money on things you don't use cancel
your unwanted subscriptions and manage
your money the easy way by going to
Rocket money.com sltr Tuesday that's
rocket money.com sltr Tuesday rocket
money.com sltr Tuesday slugs it's the
end of the year and I am so excited the
last dates of my tour are coming up
right around the corner January 7th I'll
see you in San Jose January 18th in
Portland and January 26th I'll be in
Seattle you can get tickets at EST i.com
I andot wait these are my favorite
places to visit I saved the best for
last hi sluggy I'm tuning in live for my
Christmas Eve party I'm in
Philadelphia with the fam I just wanted
to let you know where you can see me on
the road I'm so excited I've got great
dates coming up I'm going to be January
12th and 13th I'll be in
Edmonton um Alberta Canada at the comic
strip I'm then going to be at The Comedy
Store doing my next Annie wood and
Friends they've been so fun and amazing
that's January 23rd I'm going to be in
Denver col color colado February 16th
and 17th Vancouver BC for the J for
Laughs Comedy Festival February 21st
22nd I'm going to be in March an amazing
run of shows I'm going be in Fort Worth
Texas March 1st and 2nd March 8th and
9th I'm coming back to New Mexico I'm so
excited this is my first weekend in New
Mexico I'm going to be in
Albuquerque um I'm going to be in
Washington DC at the DC comedy LOF March
22nd and 23rd and Jacksonville Florida
is rescheduled for June 28th and 29th I
cannot wait to see you guys and I can
see you every Thursday on annwood love
you guys happy
holidays but who knows what I'm jumping
to and she's super sweet and I'm totally
I'm excited to hang out with her but I
was like is that kind of how this starts
for wait okay this stuff doesn't happen
to me or maybe it does and I just reject
it and um when it was offered to me but
now that I want it it's not offered to
me well when I wanted it it was nowhere
to be found and now I'm pregnant and
there's no it's not on the table that's
why yeah so you're saying I have to get
pregnant in order to like live out my my
my threesome fantasy well you know how
like the universe will like give you the
things like if you say I don't want an
adult actress right now the universe
just here's adult actress and gives it
to you okay and you're coming to
desperate you're coming from a place of
lack of an adult actress or third corre
I I will say this though the most
legendary thing you could possibly do is
have a threesome
while you're pregnant it's a forsome
it's a forsome oh my God your kid might
not like that but then the kid turns 13
starts googleing mommy seeing what Mommy
was up to finds out we're not going to
like film it no no no I just mean this
this moment it's not but I will say this
the threesome though is with a woman and
it's not like the kid is like oh there
was another dick inside mom no it's just
it's it's p it's fine totally allowed
this any know I think okay so Todd's
always like you could hook up with the
the girl and I'm like what yeah but he
so like doesn't understand the power
ofre lesbians I'm like Todd lesbians
Will Steal Your Girl 100% they will Ste
your girl and after what I saw at that
lesbian party I'm like I'm interested I
can't wait to leave Todd at 50 years old
with the children and the snakes for a
woman oh you're leaving him with the
children oh I'm abandoning my life to
become like a full-blown love Esther get
on board we don't take the children okay
obviously we go live out the full ass
Fantasy on island well I'm having a kid
old I'm having a kid old so I can't like
if I wait till they're 18 it's going to
be too dried up right I got to leave
them young no way I'm going full blast
hormones baby you know that you know the
thing about okay two things is your your
subconscious and your thoughts about
yourself are supposed to develop like
from birth to age seven like the things
that you hear under seven are like the
things that stick with you that's how
you like place your identity and stuff
so we're basically when we do all this
work work on ourselves we're just trying
to undo those things also the amount of
pressure that puts on a parent to know
that is so scary but as it should but
Gabor mate also says that you cannot go
wrong like there's a lot of things you
think your child needs but really it
just needs consistent love yeah and that
feeling of like Mom and Dad care and
love me yeah also and sorry that we'll
go back to what you're saying cuz I am
excited to hear I'll try remember but my
best friend's mom we were talking about
like you know what how my parents me up
whatever how anyone's parents mess them
up and she's like whatever you think
you're fixing you're going to mess them
up in that different way I was like oh
that takes so much pressure off okay I
think it's intuitive intuitive I have no
clue about parenting I've never even
heard into parenting I'm sure it's a
thing it's going to be your baby you're
going to look at your baby and know what
to do right you're going to know there's
no like wait but what are you saying
about like too much of a plan will be
that will be their problem so 0o to
seven and we're undoing that and then I
was thinking about leaving your kid at
10 oh my god when you're 50 me myself
but I was thinking it reminded me a lot
of my I have I have tons of friends who
are uh women that are in their 50s and
um I was talking to them and they were
telling me that that a lot of times the
reason women like people either get
divorced within the beginning of their
marriage or in their late 40s or early
50s because they start to go through
menopause and they lose the hormones
that let them suffer a man's [__]
that s they can no longer deal with the
[__] I'm so glad that Dave won't go
through menopause he might have already
he doesn't suffer your [__] right now
yeah that actually checks out for me
like they're just like but can I also
say I don't think I had to hit menopause
to get to that stage I was just gon to
say that cuz I'm like I can sniff you
out miles away at this point yeah yeah
like the only person whose [__] I'll
put up with is obviously the person who
um have an unhealthy relationship with
is Bobby my ex but you're putting up
with him in a different way you broke
the the relationship part of it the
Romantic so now you're putting up with
it it is a b even though you have very
few boundaries in your relationship that
is a boundary that you guys are not
romantic anymore yeah that is true
speaking of um no skin almost
ovulating I think I start in two days I
kled when you said that I am becoming
like weirdly attracted to you
something's happening I'm like friend
crush I'm like I'm trying I'm calling
her I'm like I'm like like is there a
Vibe I was like there a Vibe she did not
respond by the way it was silence on the
other hand I was like okay been
there I was like is this friendship 2.0
but I said .0 or something yeah she goes
is this friendship point0 and like I
think I I and then she laughed and then
ignored me and she was like I got to go
clean I was like I was like well this is
an uncomfortable feeling so I know how
to fix it I'll just go clean my house
but I wasn't really uncomfortable wait
should we do our new routine which is
our weekly top of show like little
check-in how are you doing today what's
going on sure not to be like the
Little Nerd with my glasses I know it's
like not to be the Little
Nerd oops wrong outfit you know what I I
have to say eser I think that you're
really feeling yourself at this stage in
your pregnancy because of the red
nails and you are holding yourself a
little bit sexier these past couple days
she's finally into you think this is all
coming from me now you don't want it you
sent it to the universe thank you for
that finally eat
your thank you so much um I can't have
any sexual relations because it'll make
it'll cause me physical pain she'll lose
her position as the president but um
well okay let's I'll start with the
check-in then with that little prompt I
am definitely feeling I've had a couple
decent days in the pregnancy lately and
I'm like really excited about that and
last night was my show at the comedy
store and it was like a smashing success
like it was so fun and I think I'm still
high off of it and like I was saying
last week like that extra appreciation I
have that I can actually do this like
I'm just so grateful for this career
right now like that we can get on stage
share these weird crazy thoughts
entertain people connect with people who
are similar to you like everyone has
like a live experience we're like all
for 90 minutes not looking at our phones
like it it just I'm feeling the
appreciation for it and so I think like
I've that's carrying over with me this
morning and yes I'm like okay I got the
Lululemon a lion a legging leggings that
all the maternity girls say are like
lowkey the best maternity hilarious I
wear them I didn't know they were from
maternity they're
not they're the on that b out right they
that's what they do they have all
different kinds of like leg but it's
like that they have like the wide top
yeah it's really good for my muffin top
yes it's great and um some maybe it's
just like the Align
leggings glow I feel you on the legging
really no I and they're so like the
smoothness of them it just makes you so
happy it makes me realize do you
remember this I don't know about the
scrunch for the thing but I'm going to
forgive it's not my business tall Uggs
I'm going all I know but with the when
you want it tight all the way down
that's because I had to size up a bunch
because I'm going to grow into these and
because I but I forgive it and it's my
judgment thank you but like nothing can
be too tight right now but I heard
there's two different kinds of Uggs
there's UGG Australia and then there are
Uggs here and apparently the quality is
completely different of course we're
getting the shitty American ugs and
we've been getting the bad ones since
like y 2K it's not even like new yeah
these ones are cute are these new these
are new yeah very cute comfy clothes
because I dated an Australian boy and he
got me the Australian uggs and they have
been I mean I have put those things
through like actual like they've I've
put them in a fire and they didn't melt
oh my God that's your Stanley Cup that's
my they're going to send you a car now
wait I have a question though are are
Uggs are fake now right oh I don't know
or are we wearing an animal I think
they're faux now or I don't know I
literally don't know because I just
remember always seeing um Pamela
Anderson and them so I'm like they could
be real talking
I feel like they were real they were
were absolutely real I was I just want
to say I'm okay with sticking my foot
straight into a do they kill the Lambs
to get their first they shave them but
then those animals don't necessarily
live great lives oh they just shave them
oh they just shave them yeah but it's
like you know if imagine like I can't
imagine mass production of shaving or
mass shavings being like a fun thing for
a l that actually sounds really fun if
we did a mass
shaving wait that's a really cute term
guys Mass shaving that's our next live
stream that's our next moment house is a
mass shaving everybody get your razor we
got to get a razor sponsor okay check in
talk to okay wait I have a question a
moral question moral okay if we found
out this glitter was tested on the same
sheep that your feet are inside still
wearing it how good is the
makeup or do we try to like I don't have
the bandwidth during pregnancy to check
that stuff like 6 months ago I was you
know I remember with the contact
everything everything was more but it's
like I am I'm a busy mom and I just if
there's glitter in the ey shadow that
you get you were so generous to give to
me um you know you know what else
another rule that kind of translates
here is when you go to someone's house
for dinner you eat what they serve and
you don't like follow all your own
dietary restrictions and so I'm like you
gave me the glitter I already have it
I'm using it that's what's happening I
love that so I can just buy you weird
Shir oh
no this is friendship 2.0 for us do not
bring me like fugra or something but
what if your baby wants it my baby my
why would my baby want fagra you don't
know until it's in front of you it's not
happening cuz you your baby is your baby
they they do what you say oh I don't not
a parent but that's what my sister
always say she's like you raised your
kid like to be your kid and know I don't
really know what it means that did not
work out for my mom boy did I go then
they turned 14 I remember the moment I
sat up in bed and I was like I can call
her a [__] back oh my God it was the
most powerful moment of my life you're
kidding I was like you're a b they were
like it was over then you're a [__] B
what Happ any how are you guys feeling
today um colorful I feel cute as [__] I
love my outfit I love my spray tan even
though the pits are very white
um I did a very good Pilates today I'm
just going to come out and say it I am
taking
semaglutide and I have to talk about it
because you guys I don't know about this
shortage cuz it was very easy to get so
I don't know what's going on but thank
you and very cheap and very cheap and
it's so funny because when I through
this doctor when I was offered it I was
like I don't think I want to do it like
this just isn't my vibe or whatever but
then I had like a fomo about it and I
was like I want to try this thing out it
was offered to me it's easy to get and I
was like all right it was like $300 and
then it was sitting in my fridge and I
was like I don't think I want this like
I don't want to have stomach problems
and then I was like I actually am not
someone that has bad side effects to
things and if I do have a bad side
effect I'll stop doing it I'm not trying
to get like skinny like all these things
I was like maybe I could lose 10 pounds
or whatever but I just was more out of
curiosity trying it but now I'm
literally like it's cured my desire to
lose any weight it's like so weird
there's like this now this weird Paradox
where I'm I'm like all right I got a
taper off of it when when I start to
lose too much weight or whatever and
then I like cuz I the effects of it I
looked it up and this has been known to
do it it's like curing my ADD what do
you mean do it just cure the compulsion
I I'm like it's not hard to get to
exercise I don't have that voice in my
head that's like like just lay in bed
just lay in bed it's like I'm like I
want to work out and when I'm going like
I went to Pilates today two days this
week and wait you have a voice that says
just lay in bed it's so hard for me cuz
you such an Energizer Bunny know it's
like just stay it's easier to stay
really Sor how is it you're affecting
your relationship with food well I just
don't it's just very easy to eat just
what I choose to eat so you still eat
you still have an appetite I would
refuse I would never not eat that's like
not I have no interest and I do think
like not to be judgmental but I do see
some people that have been on OIC and
stuff I don't like how they look I don't
think I think at at 40 I've crossed the
threshold of skinny being hot it just
looks sick for me my personal judgment
on that is like it's not like I'm not
chasing like lowrise jeans or anything
you know I really like being fit and I
did hear that like it can if you don't
work out it can like go and like you can
lose muscle and I have no interest in
that so I just have been working out
harder but it's like very easy like when
I go to a class like let's say back in
the day when we used to go to Barry's
boot camp once or twice I don't remember
how many times we went I don't think we
ever even went together we never went
together but I did go we had we had an
era it which is for both of us I feel
like it's never coming back for me but I
like okay so I they always go you can
put the tread mode like 4.5 or 4.5 up to
like 7.5 like I very rarely got to 7.5
and if I did it's like I had to like
really fight myself to get there I am
now like 10.5 like I go as hard as I can
like I'm so sore I used to think Pilates
was so easy it's because I wasn't trying
hard I was like what's the least amount
of workout I can do during this workout
I'm like squeezing my core I'm just like
I don't know I've a Lust For Life I have
a Lust For Life oh my God my you guys my
Shaman just called me and my [__]
hypnotist it's it's it's my angels my
angels just called me it's cuz you don't
need them anymore because of the
semaglutide I love them though I want to
give it to all for Christmas can I
Christmas is over can I say something
you the three of you have never looked
you look very stunning today oh thank
you in different ways oh my go her
second divorce is making her lesbo
honestly she's in per menopause um
I just wanted you to know you all are
like glowing thank you Stella so are you
I there's like a full camera in front of
you but I'm assuming great you can't see
me at all I'm assuming you look great
wait and Stella thank you so much for
coming to the show last night what did
you have fun The Comedy Store is very I
don't know how to describe it it's
honestly is just it's a cool place you
feel very cool when you go there it's
the best place on Earth and then you
when you know the people [__] yeah you
feel like and then like even watching
Esther like stand up and they kept
talking about about like I know you're
here for Esther I was like man that must
be such a cool feeling like also just to
see that Annie was in the other room and
like I don't know I love going there I
feel very very cool I feel like it's
like a very cool place by the way when I
got there your show was just letting out
and I did an accidental mini meet and
greet at your show was like not on
purpose I was like yeah and I there was
a lot of trash Tuesday fans there and of
course I was like how do you like the
new I was like asked questioning them
about the new Vibe and they were all
like we love it even though they
probably were just saying we don't give
you guys an option to not like it okay
this is hypnosis this is the best it's
ever been it's always going to get
better and yeah you're the slug fans are
so sweet it was so cute there were so
many people but it was it was also
really cool it was like watching Beyonce
pregnant perform wow honestly you know
what I wanted to say too that's really
cool it's like you're kind of like in
this this you're so in the moment and
what's going on it's got to feel so good
on stage to because sometimes I think
like like as all Comics like we kind of
get like stuck in a set for a while and
it's like we're not even like in that
place in our lives anymore like you're
like pregnant talking about being
pregnant and it's so [__] relatable I
just could not do the not in the Moment
On Stage anymore cuz it was taking away
it was just like draining me of there's
no like Joy yeah the Artistry of it or
something um wait but okay before KLA
check in I just want to ask Stella what
did you think CU Dave joined me on stage
for the last like 15 minutes what did
you what was your opinion of Dave I want
Dave to I would love Dave to come on um
the podcast she's like I'm not sure yet
we'll have to see I need to interview I
I thought it was very cute you got your
little like the way that you went back
and forth was really cute I feel like he
was really adorable but I want more I
want to know more I had like questions
okay good to know I I thought it was
cute though okay and you can tell that
he really like and then at one point
he's like I don't know why I'm up here
like I thought it was yeah I liked that
no he's still he's like when is it going
to be me Todd and Bobby like Bobby
should just or Bobby why don't we just
hard launch hard launch Me and Bobby
back together no oh oh the guy I'm
seeing Oh no there's no hard launches
there absolutely not I'm protect we kept
him anonymous we put like a screen over
him and he just talks could just put guy
there's a silhouette of him and he just
talks know keep him private I I will I
will bring him on a phone call First
like on the show and you know what I
mean don't you guys think it would be
funny if we just started the show and
the three of them well we could someone
else we could have guy or something KLA
whoever you felt comfortable with guys
in your seat we have your ex-husband in
your
seat oh yeah
honestly but that I think and then to
start whatever like hot guy or girl
Katie is banging um and then to start
the show like that I think that would be
so cute yeah I think Bobby would be down
for my correspondent I liked our episode
when we dressed like our our mom that
was really funny I'm like still dressing
like like that that like you never CH
that was your steveann that was your
Steve Bannon phas wait KLA checkin how
are you today what's going on what's
what's how you feeling um
uh I was supposed to have therapy this
week but my therapist is getting back
surgery so she's out for a long time
it's like you can't FaceTime no but you
know what's you know what's crazy is
that you think that you like you need it
right therapy but then you really feel
like you need it when you can't have it
when you're like I'm out I can't help
you so now I'm like who do I call like
you know like and it's just it's it's
not no crisis or anything but it's that
feeling of like I I think I need like
assistance yes and um but but I'm good
I'm good today surviving I think it's
gonna be she's gonna have a wild ride is
your therapist a girl my therapist is a
lady yeah she's gonna have a wild ride
and when she gets back to
work it's going to be all saved up I
know I know well you know that just made
me think of my um childhood doctor
passed away when I was like still pretty
young I was like a teenager and it there
was like a weird betrayal cuz he was so
like Precious and like our our guy he
got brain cancer imagine what it would
feel like if just suddenly our therapist
passed away like do you imagine can you
imagine the amount of that would be
pretty rough in fact um starting over is
like starting over is a lot it's it's a
lot but there are upsides to starting
over because like you are like kind of a
new version of yourself I think you know
at different times in your life and
there are some things you no longer have
to talk about yeah you know like oh I've
already addressed that I don't have to
keep like they want the summary and
you're like oh can you like is there a
file with the notes yeah but what what I
like even because I switched therapists
like four years ago five years ago and
um I liked like picking and choosing
like oh wait I've already addressed this
this doesn't um bother me anymore and I
don't need to bring that into like my
sessions now like we've processed that
like we're good that's true I like you
kind of close the chapter and it's like
I like that my therapist knows that
those things existed though but you're
right like it would be okay if someone
knew didn't have all the files uploaded
have you ever had friends that lie to
their therapist my friend in college was
like oh I always lie to my therapist I'm
like what that's such a waste of money
it's so insane but but I will say as
someone who has lied to
You' talked about this yeah I've
absolutely lied to my therapist I told
Dr Drew this it's it's me still being a
people pleaser like it's me still
feeling like like there are moments
where she's like how are you I'm like
I'm good I'm hanging in there and and
I'm not I'm like barely hanging on by a
thread but I'm like I'm good I got this
and I don't got this that's not I don't
think that's that's a bad lie cuz that's
also kind of like you're also maybe even
like speaking yourself into a truth like
maybe you're trying to talk yourself
into it or even if you're trying to make
them please them or whatever it's not
that's not that bad but it's like I had
friends that would like lie about like
things that happened they were just
weirdos was College I not about big
stuff no no no like I feelings I think
is kind of okay cuz they'll probably
yeah like there are times where she's
like here's where I've lied where she's
like I think it's this and I think it's
because you know she'll go into the
whole racial part of like my trauma
where she's like you know you're
Filipino this and that and this she gets
and I'm like I don't think it's that but
I'll nod and be like oh yeah you're
right it might be that and I'm like I
don't actually agree with you there and
it's very people pleasy but I want to
hear her out so I just it is awkward to
be like even if it's your therapist or
someone else when someone is so
confident they figured out what your
deals it is really uncomfortable to be
like no I don't think it's that even as
someone who is not a people pleaser and
will speak up it's it's awkward yeah I
like though I like with my new therapist
she's like she goes like I what like I'm
guessing like she doesn't she's very
like conscious of that and there's been
times I'm like no I don't think that's
it that doesn't like ring true but I'll
try it on you know and I think like with
a lot of my friends like when they call
me for things and I'm like I'm going to
guess like I just like never I always
like preface I could be totally wrong
but like if I were you I might be
feeling it because of this you know man
you guys I have to be honest I am still
struggling in my life with this one
recurring theme that is coming up with
like family friends it's I'm seeing it
in multiple relationships where someone
I love so much is in a relationship
romance with a romantic relationship
that I don't approve of and it's like
are you talking about Todd yeah Todd and
I have been talking I'm begging him I am
it is this is just like I I can't let go
it's really hard for me to keep quiet
even though I do
it it's so hard and then if they even
and they ask questions even if I've
prepped myself like don't don't there
they these two people love each other
like you cannot get in between them but
if someone goes what are you I'm like I
think this and this and this and then I
know they're never going to they're
they're in love they're never going to
well if they're asking you explicitly
then you can unload they and they know
what you're going to say probably but
they don't helped me but you helped me
before and I didn't hear it yet like you
helped me in one of my relationships
where you were like this is not a good
guy this guy's not into you this is like
and you didn't so but you and even if I
didn't hear it then like later I was
like oh yeah but it's helpful it's like
yeah I've had that too with a friend
where she told me this the way this guy
is treating you is she told me all the
reasons why that wasn't working I wasn't
ready when she said it but then later I
was like yeah she was right cuz if
you're like then you can I I think
honestly in that not that you ask for
advice but like I think in that
situation I would be like either like I
can't like talk I can't be the one that
you talk to about this because I just
have my feelings and I don't want to get
involved but I can't control myself but
okay but it would just be like a
boundary yeah but you have to like the
way I see it is like like choose your
own [__] Adventure bit you want to
choose heartache and Devastation that's
the road you want to go like how about
it like you care about your of course of
course but I think the nicest thing that
my family ever did was never intrude on
my relationships cuz I learned a lot
through the horable ones you don't want
to be an experience dealer you want to
steal someone's experience I really felt
like Ed I'm like okay they trust that
okay maybe this person isn't great but
they trusted me to crawl out of it and
get out of it even though it was
probably hard to watch for them cuz I'm
sure they were just [__] foaming at
the mouth wanting to be like [__]
leave him but they don't do that and I
really they I really love my family for
that because it's like even though those
things hurt and even though there are
times where I'm like why the [__] didn't
you tell me they were like Kila like
like you have you had to go through it
you just had and I know you're right
because you know what this happened I've
talked when I brought about brought this
up before it was about my sister and
she's finally out of that relationship
no thanks to me being right the whole
time like she had to get there herself
nothing I said got her there nothing and
of course cuz she's my [__] [__]
sister she's never going to be like you
were right but like so I've SE I'm just
I've seen me try and it gets me nowhere
and they have to do it themselves but
here I am in this again with someone
else and I'm like it's also you can't
like control someone else it's like you
can't like get there understand it's
also yeah like you let them hit their
bottom faster yeah like do you know what
I mean it's like if you don't Aid them
if you don't like just jump in and they
they might hit the bottom of that
relationship faster cuz Okay like for
instance um I was dating somebody and I
wasn't disclosing to my family how
actually mean he was to me like on text
he was very jealous this is pretty
pretty recent he was very nasty when he
wouldn't like get his way with me he
would call me things like avoidant he
would say that I was a [__] that he
would like I was like when you first
said avoidant I was like not he would
say things
like yeah but he would say things like
oh like I you you give um too many
people you look you give too many men
eye contact and I'm like where am I
going like I don't even leave the
[__] house old for this sh like one
time like I spent 4 hours on face time
with him and I went to an Easter party
for an hour and a half and I didn't
check in in with him for that hour and a
half and I came home to like a barrage
of text messages basically being like
why the [__] are you like this like and
mind you I I had just spent four hours
on anyways all of this to say at 38 I
was I put up with this [__] at 38
having gone through all of the shitty
relationships and this is the only time
my sister was like thank [__] God
okay so he did something that was very
similar in the same vein of being
jealous and being like just not cool and
yeah controlling and I and and finally I
called my sister I was in Hawaii and I
was like hey I think I'm done with this
she goes yes you are yes the [__] you
are and she's like and if you are not
I'm actually going to step in this time
she's like if you were 25 you put up
with that because you don't know any
better but I was like Kila you just got
out of a 30 10 year relationship you're
30 38e relationship yeah basically well
basically because you sold yourself out
to being that other one yeah and then um
she was like yeah you are you're done
we're done well how did you hit that
wall of you're done with this
controlling person I I hate to say this
but there was a catalyst I was there was
a a guy that I met who was a friend and
his presence made me feel very calm
secure and he was just a friend and like
cared for and just looking at him I was
like wait I cannot be with someone like
this when I I know there are people like
this like who Cal my nervous system I'm
like why am I in this and then I called
it was like 1: in the morning she picked
up and she was like yeah you're done I'm
like I'm done and it felt soing good
because I think I was very lonely when I
broke up with Bobby um I I wanted to you
know I I I just wanted maybe to feel
someone's like warm body next to me to
feel adore it again cuz I felt ugly all
understandable yeah and I got myself
into something not not healthy you know
I wish him well and stuff but like yeah
dude like I I I did not tell my family
all of the nasty stuff that he was
saying and I almost was like only told
him the good stuff but my sister knew it
the whole time she was like that boy is
controlling like she just sniffed it out
I'm glad to hear that you got there on
your own and that gives me hope that I
can just cuz I know this is my issue why
do I care I should step back and that's
that's what I need to do and let them
pull Kila and find it yeah just trust
that they're going to be okay and they
can figure it out people like do unless
someone's being like physically hurt and
you need to like step in it's like I
think it's like people always go to that
but I'm like I think some of these it's
all bad but you're I know you're right
unless there's like they're going to be
killed I don't know yeah you know I mean
and there's B yeah as long as their
safety is okay you know you're right you
guys are right but it's like yeah I mean
I think obviously verbal abuse has like
a big impact on people but you can't
call the cops and be like some called me
a horor you hate that it even has to be
that way but it's like you really have
to check in with how your body feels
around the person cuz sometimes you're
so used to feeling a certain way and you
sometimes can flate that that like
anxiety with like ooh it must be
butterflies or it must be this really
your nervous system is just shutting
down and you get you get in the habit
when you have like so much trauma when
you're little of like excitement is that
like that that's like that's everything
is like and then you just h hadit a
point where like I want to peace I just
want to be like happy and peace I don't
want have to be like so high or low all
the time that's why do what dror what
was he said to you like go for calm yeah
no fireworks yeah like because you know
for someone like me maybe even someone
like you or all of us it's like we've
been through and our nervous system is
just really fried you need that calm you
need that Safe Harbor and I think I
always wanted to go for the chaos and
like you know the bells and whistle cuz
that's always what's exciting to me
that's like my family structure is very
exciting like that I have a question I
don't have any clue what the answer is
to it but um what do you think and I'm
just using men as the example because
we're women and we mostly date guys but
what do you think causes a controlling
guy like what in their childhood makes
them controll okay well I before you
said childhood I was going to say but
that's I'm really curious about that too
it's obviously like jealous insecurity
they're just so I think it's that they
don't trust women and that has something
to do with childhood young experience
maybe their first love or maybe
something to do with Mommy I don't know
but like it's a control it's I don't
trust you unless you're you must be in
my sight at all times or I think I I
know David So fought me on this but it's
like you know those guys that think all
women are [__] and they're never going
to that that's their core belief and so
whatever you do they're just maybe it's
like a cheating mother I think it's
people manifest their anxieties that's
what they say men men go outward women
go Inward and I can I can I say for me
what it was because I was the super
jealous super jealous insane girlfriend
in my 20s and I will admit like super
unhealthy and probably accused people of
doing things that they would never even
dare of doing but for me it was like I
was very much the girl in in guy friend
groups that was the recipient of all of
their bad stories like like I was always
the girl that were like oh kalila like
if they would like cheat on their girls
or their wives or whatever for some
reason they thought I was the vault in
the group and maybe there was a part of
me that was very pck me and I'm like oh
yeah like I'm the girl that the guys
trust but then I became the recipient of
all of their [__] bad behavior I
would witness it and so when I got into
my relationships I'm like oh you're just
like all my other friends I'm sure like
you're all terrible and I know this for
a fact and I see their girlfriends like
girlfriends of my friends or wives and
who were completely unaware and in my
head I'm like I'm not going to that
unaware I'm going to be on to you I'm
going to sniff you out honestly that's a
[__] losing game of course it is life
yeah it's it's it number one my partners
probably didn't deserve that absolutely
didn't deserve that also like I I'm just
in I'm just spinning for no reason they
sucked though who knows yeah pself I've
definitely been cheated on like several
times like in my younger years but I
don't even think that's why I became a
jealous person I think it's have hearing
the stories over and over again also cuz
I was really jealous too and I didn't
even realize I I can't remember what
friend it was but I remember just asking
her these questions like so you don't
know what your boyfriend what he's up to
right now no what if he's doing this
whatever and I was like whoa it could be
like this like and I and I'm like oh
that's so much better than this other
version where you're ruining your own
[__] life trying to control someone
either and I always say this to my other
friend I'm like you either trust the
person you're with or you don't and it
doesn't really matter what it's just do
you have peace or do you not have peace
there's no in between right and this
friend never has peace and I'm like okay
that sucks I hate this for you there's
nothing I can do well also it's just
like if you're jealous and possessive
you're thinking about someone else all
the time you're not like even like
focusing on your whole life is on hold
your whole life is on hold and I see
this and I've been there like like
you're saying I've totally been there
too maybe that's maybe there is a
projecting going on where it's like God
I know what that's like and there's life
on another there's life on the other
side of that and I want to bring you
there yeah and it's such a great place
to be when you're like I don't give a
[__] if you do or you don't like I'm
gonna sit with the trust of it all and
like live in the peace for instance like
the guy that I'm dating very social very
lovable people like him he has Fem
friends it's like that's what I'm
attracted to it's also what makes me
like a little bit like it brings back
like a little bit of my old like jealous
habits but so I mean look a scooch of
jealousy H like a scooch like if you
know they're choosing you like yeah if
you know they're choosing you it's very
fun for a girl to hit on your man yeah
if you know that they're
not but also within reason nothing too
crazy but also like if they don't know
you exist like if you just watch like
some like someone like come to your like
look at your man or whatever and they
don't know that you're not like next to
them yet that's [__] hot but I think
it it speaks to what you said earlier
about like not giving a [__] you kind of
lose that um the hormones to give a [__]
and I don't I think for me it's kind of
like I really now I believe I can leave
anytime and I am okay alone and if this
doesn't work out and you turn out to be
a [__] like [__] it we tried cool
like I'm not devastated anym more at the
thought of being alone because it turns
out it's quite nice yeah even when I
have dreams like sometimes I have dreams
that Todd cheats on me and even in the
dreams I'm like I'll be okay this sucks
but I'm going to get through this like
I'm even like being like healthy yeah
this is why it is so important for women
to be financially like independent
because I've never had a guy that has
money like this conversation is so
insane to me but know one of my
girlfriends was saying this recently
like it's women must have their
financial Independence so that they have
the freedom to like you said so easily
like you know we can just go be on our
own because if you are not in that
situation scary but I also heard one of
my many Shaman gurus once told me like
he was like you know always leave a
situation never let money be the thing
because just statistically you always
you always make like within two years
you're financially sound like that's
enough time for you to like rebuild a b
business or or anything like that which
I think is really good to hear too it's
like where you're like oh everything is
going to like how could it if you're
forward moving and you want to make
money you can make money you know like
you can find a way somehow on the
internet hopefully on the internet and
not like in an alley on your knees or
whatever but that's also an option
create a TI to shop but I was thinking
about um yeah the homeless people in my
neighborhood are like knitting I'm like
you have an Etsy store this is crazy but
I was thinking about something you said
okay I need more
semaglutide I just have a question
because I'm newly single right now I'm
in that phase where I'm like I will date
a toxic man just to feel a hot like a
warm body yeah so between the toxic
person and the great per like what was
the time like between the two was it a
long period between the breakup and then
dating a good person yeah well to be
clear like he didn't seem like toxic at
first I'm not like pointing out like oh
yeah he seems this way well they never
do but yeah they never do I think I'm
also old enough to know that I actually
don't think like there's he's he's a
great guy I think that our Dynamic was
toxic because you know at this time in
my life like I when we were dating he
was ready for a relationship and I was
very clear upfront about not wanting to
be in a relationship and that back and
forth really frustrated him to the point
of like I think him being like an
anxious kind of type of person guy if
he's calling you a [__] though I do
that too always like I don't call people
I'm always like I'm always like oh but
he's not and I'm like I'm kind of done
doing that cuz it's like I can be like I
like wish you well and I hope you learn
and I hope you like grow and find what
you need in the world but why am I
always like I'm almost like apologizing
I'm like putting like what what they did
to me like I'm like oh but it's okay you
know what they call that I learned it
from the holistic psychologist an over
understander like where you make excuses
for people cuz you're like they went
through this trauma and it's because of
this and you know I understand where
he's coming from and it's like sometimes
you're right like I don't want to be
called a [__] I don't want to be called
this and that like I understand where
what led you to say that but it doesn't
mean I have to put up with it can I tell
you guys something that I I had like a
little bit of like a not a breakdown in
Philly when I was back for Thanksgiving
but when I went back home like this this
girl that I that had done some like up
[__] to me when we were in high school
she's like incredibly successful in her
field there and I had this like feeling
of like when I she kind of popped Po in
my head when last time I was doing iasa
and I was like oh I'm like proud of her
you know like that's great that she got
to like the top of her thing and then
when I was in Philly and I was thinking
about it and I was like I had had this
urge to like go see her and like say
there was this thing inside me that like
was like oh I should go see her and tell
her I'm proud of her and whatever and
it's like I need to kill that part of
myself because my my sadness when I was
there and I was like actually thinking
about it was like what is it in me that
keeps giving people these like chances
it's like this person like and of course
she was 16 at the time it really doesn't
matter what was done in that situation
was bad enough to sever that cord
forever and I think it's like what I
strive to do is have no feelings about
it like obviously I don't want people to
be like homeless on the street or like
feeling like [__] or whatever and having
a bad life but it's like I was just like
sad about the fact that I was like
willing to like okay so what's coming up
for me is that this is an extremely
common uh behavior that often women
experience with like an
abuser where they want to make things
right with the person who hurt them and
I don't know the psychology or why it is
but it's like you often like want to
make sure things are cool with like the
guy who you or whatever it is I don't
know if you guys have that experience in
your sexual trauma but it's very common
and that's it's like oh she did
something [__] up to you and you have
this maybe like she would like maybe she
was going to apologize to me or
something like it's almost like I'm
going and thinking but I don't know what
it is because it's not I'm not even like
thinking about it's just like the fact
that I'm like oh like let bygones be got
by guns it's like I'm done like I I
don't like that I don't think that's
like a healthy kindness that I have you
know you should really talk to my sister
cuz she is the best person like she
understands core wounds so well so any
one who bullied her in elementary school
I always tell her it's like Kaa it's
like you were eight n years old she's
like I don't give a that face is
emblazened in my mind and it elicits a
certain response out of me I don't care
if we were seven or eight it's a [__]
wound that is that is still there so
it's like I don't care if they want to
have you know because we go back to the
Philippines and and they're like oh
let's all grab dinner she's like I don't
want to see that person's face because
when I see that look at that person's
face I'm back to being
and that's okay
too the only thing that gets in the way
of me playing slots in Vegas is that I
don't live in Vegas and the fact that I
am able to on my phone play Slots with
DraftKings is like the most exciting
news and pretty upsetting for my
business manager but very exciting for
me also not just slots by the way
Blackjack roulette they have all of it
you don't understand I'll be at the
comedy store I'll literally hear from
another room W what and I'm like it's
Annie on the draft ke Casino do you know
like sometimes there's people gathering
around her it's a party when Annie has
that app open and right now new players
who play $5 get $100 instantly in Casino
credits I love that the minimums are low
you can play as low or as high stakes as
you feel on a given day and some
sometimes for your business manager it's
high stakes also if you're like me maybe
you're not ready to play for real money
no problem all DraftKings games let you
test out the games for free to find the
right fit so sometimes I'll have fun
doing that download the DraftKings
casino app now and sign up with promo
code trash Tuesday and play $5 to get
$100 in Casino credits that's promo code
trash Tuesday only at DraftKings Casino
the crown is yours gambling problem call
1800 Gambler or visit www. 18800
gambler. net in Connecticut help is
available for problem gambling call
8887895118
terms at casino. drop
kings.com holidays onth house
restrictions apply I think it's no
secret that we all struggle to save
money every month yeah I'm so good at
spending it though I was like I really
have a gift I really have a gift you
actually are better than most I have a
gift I buy I I I spend it on everything
and you look good thank you I I I think
it works but with rocket money you can
quickly identify all of those sneaky
subscriptions which are so freaking hard
to cancel also most people think that
they're spending about $80 per month on
subscriptions and the reality is it's
much closer to $200 a month so we all
like kind of do our girl math and make
us make ourselves think it's less rocket
money is a personal finance app that
findes and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place with over 5 million users in
counting rocket money has helped save
its customers an average of
$720 a year and $1 billion in savings so
far think all that was for Annie yes for
me and what I love about rocket money
too is they can help you negotiate your
bills lower stop wasting money on things
you don't use cancel your unwanted
subscriptions and manage your money the
easy way by going to Rocket money.com
Tuesday that's rocket money.com Tuesday
rocket
money.com
[Music]
Tuesday and it's almost like it's not
even like my goal is like to not even
like make nice or keep a grudge or
anything it's like I just want to
vibrate on a level where I don't even
see these people anymore that's where
she's at she's just like she's like I
don't know why like it's not okay for me
just to not have feelings about it like
I don't give a [__] anymore I don't want
to see those people cuz my high school
like after all that [__] happened I went
I used to go back really I used to go
back this is this is and I would go back
and they would treat me like [__]
[__] again and it was crazy and I would
just keep going back and there was like
this alumni page where you would say
like where you are and I was doing
something way cooler than everyone else
and comedy and [__] and I would like
submit it this was like before I really
realized like how [__] up it was what
happened to me and that it wasn't normal
I was still in this weird like I
probably did something wrong I would
like submit my like alumni thing and
they wouldn't post it it was like you
like you're not posting my alumni [__]
you pieces of [__] obviously they're
probably like we got to try to erase
this [__] being in our lives yeah
because I think they put a hole in you
and you're still trying to fill that
hole somehow and I think that's I don't
have it with them anymore cuz they reach
out sometimes with and I they are done I
wish Dr Drew is here to like B break
down what this phenomenon we another Dr
Drew why it happens because I relate to
that too it's like someone does
something really bad to you and then you
want to make excuses and be like well it
wasn't like the over understander and
like and then you want to make it okay
and I don't know why we do that but it
is some kind of human nature I don't
know if it's like comes to wanting to
feel safe I think there's a safety
element there for sure it's also like
for me it's like I'm just trying to put
the puzzle pieces like together and in a
very neat way in my mind and if I have
um a period at the end of this sentence
and like an ending to that story or a
resolution or an apology somehow I'm
able to put the pieces of my life
together a little bit better in my head
and there's more of a calm because when
something is unresolved I do feel like
not great but the lesson in that for us
is like that's an outside circumstance
right like we can't control that
resolution if the if we need the
resolution to be like coming from
someone else especially someone who's
like already wronged us it's like we
have absolutely no control over that
like maybe we'll get that maybe we won't
but it's like about we have to resolve
it in ourselves energetically and that's
like that was like what I was realizing
like I need to do some work on that
because it's like I over forgive it's
like why like I also think though that
this is such a Universal response that
it must be so deep in the brain it's
like we don't even have the awareness
and I'm even like does it have something
to do with if I go back and make things
right then they won't be a then they
won't want to hurt me again are we just
like thinking deep in our subconscious
they're going to hurt me again I I
really I don't know I'm fully guessing
but this is like so not uncommon my
therapist in high school told me that a
lot of like sa um victims will go back
back to like relive that same type of
pattern not necessarily with the same
person because they want to see it
through like with a happy ending but he
also got me beer for my 16th birthday
and told me when I was going to Germany
when I was 14 that I should tell him if
the German guys have crooked penises so
I don't think we and he did more stuff
that I won't even talk about but so I
don't know if we can believe him he I'm
like oh you're one of the things I'm
doing this with wait I want to I want to
bring something up that I recently found
out um have you have you guys ever heard
of the correlation between when you have
your period and what kind of witch you
are no okay cuz I know you guys thought
it was very woo woo of me the a couple
episodes ago and I was like I bleed with
a moon cuz I bleed with a full moon
right woo woo woo up woo woo is all I
want okay so I I've bled with a full
moon for as long as I can remember there
are times where it it flips into me um
ovulating with a full moon but it's
either ovulating on on a full moon but
mostly bleeding with a full moon always
on a full moon I'm just imagining you
have like hot period sucks under the
moon but apparently there's so if you
bleed with a full moon you're called a
red witch if you ovulate on a full moon
it's a white witch and there's pink
witch and there's other types so I want
to know what you guys are and each one
has their own powers I have never
compared my period to the size of the mo
to yeah we'll have to wait for her for a
while but it makes so much sense because
I mean the moon dictates tide right it
dictates fish activity it dictates so
many don't call our vaginas fish
activity it dictates so many like things
in nature like why wouldn't it um you
know what makes you think to check the
moon when you bleed that's what I want
to know no because it's so I know that
my period is coming it's very easy for
me to know are you sure you're not
Native American I'm
not so it's like if I just know when the
full moon is that month then I can
prepare when to get tampons and stuff
stuff like that I don't even need a
period tracker cuz I'm like I just bleed
with a mood all I'm saying is can you
track your periods and eser the next
time you do have one or go back to your
period track or how about that and you
let me know will you let me know when
you bleed so we can figure out what kind
of witches we are yes I will say this
makes sense because if you think about
it like in whatever times when we were
cavemen or whatever we were like we
didn't have calendars or like IAL so it
makes sense that like we looked at the
moon and be like okay I'm going to bleed
soon like I guess that is there's I
better gather my leaves yeah I better
gather my twigs and leaves which one are
you I'm so I'm a red witch cuz I bleed
with the full moon so apparently I was
killed a lot back in the day why yeah
like um because the red witches were
considered um oh my God you look so
hotting heers the oracles yeah like high
priestesses and like really up to no
good in the you see Kila like being one
of the witches that like is getting
burned but she doesn't even scream
she's like you won't take I love the
heat you won't take my what does he say
braveart I was like lazza the Mohicans
or RAR yeah well I was going to say I
have extremely long Cycles so I would
never like my C cycle long or the period
what do you mean like my cycle is I only
get a period every 38 days oh I have my
period for 38 days I thought that's I
just have a heavy period for five hour
for five years no it's so weird I don't
understand why my Cycles are so long I
don't understand what it means forever
doctors like you need that's really
concerning you probably won't have be a
you're you're the P you're both you're
all of it yeah but I mean that's
[__] because like Annie's mom didn't
even have her period until she was 30
and she had twins real you know what I
mean so it's like it's it's it's a weird
thing to say but is there anything you
do at home that is just so between just
so private and just between you and
yourself and no one will ever know that
you do like for instance I'll give you
an example like when I'm at the tail end
of my period And it's like that fudgy
Brown you put it on your face that's
Filipino ritual that's that's public she
it into brownies and doesn't tell anyone
no like I pull my panty down cuz I'm I
don't put a a panty liner I don't have a
tampon on because it's a tail end right
I pull it down that's why it's called
the tail end you leave a little tail
yeah and I I say this out loud to myself
and I go
chocolate and and it's something that I
have to do every single time like I'm
like chocolate and then I go into the
shower I honestly can't relate I think
it's adorable though I love the
childlike quity I yeah I like the baby
voice there's nothing that you guys do
where you're like God if someone heard
me right now they would a lot I'm just
I'm of course everything I do is
embarrassing everything at home thanks
for clarifying at
home we've never seen you embarrass
yourself here never everything at home
cool we have a couple questions yeah
wait can I say that I went to the to the
shop today I wanted to buy flowers I
knew we were doing a thing so I wanted
to get I was like who do I get flowers
for and I decided to get them for the
fans maybe it's too big put it wait so
what is the flowers occasion cuz we were
going to do like a episode about the
fans oh I wanted to get them that's
beautiful put them on the little thing
do you guys like getting flowers I do
now once I healed myself I enjoy I
started enjoying it yeah I I really
think it's cute when if like we're
walking anywhere and a guy like picks
like random flowers and little so as
we're hiking he'll pick random at the
end of the hike he has a little thing
and he's like oh that's cute I think
you're just newly happy and in love no
I'm such a romance girl I've always been
that way just Bobby missed that memo
Bobby missed the memo completely but
I've always been like a super like soft
romance girl like that well these are
for our our slugs then right these are
for Slugs and then we have they wanted
to tell you there's a bunch of crazy
stuff that they sent us today Okay cool
so we got some fan gossip questions
Secrets submitted which we love when we
do these so thank you guys for sending
them in always do please my brother's
girlfriend caught me and my boyfriend
talking [__] about her home decor on her
pet Cam and now she's refusing to come
to my family's Christmas until I
apologize oh I I have a take I have two
takes I need to hear what was I need to
know what was said I'm just like it it
really I have a strong take that I'm
scared as people aren't going to like
okay I'm going to say this if you're
spying on people you deserve what you
get yeah you deserve what you get and
suck it up but on the other hand
sometimes just apologizing is such like
a king archetype move like just
apologize when you don't mean it just to
make things like easy and go Downstream
but also I just feel like if the
sister-in-law was asking I would be like
grow up I'd be like okay I'm so sorry
but that person violated their privacy
you're spying you're violating someone's
privacy don't look for things that you
don't want to see like we are all
allowed to in the privacy of our own
home or in the private conversation say
whatever we want and we might say bad
things about our family people we love
human nature okay and that sucks that
you SPI and you caught that no that I'm
sure that feels like [__] for this
person but also like home decor is not
the worst also it's for you it's like
who would you decorate your house for
your in-laws like who cares it's for
yourself you also if you like your house
looks why does it matter if someone
that's a little Psychopathic to me love
know if I'm going to Strongarm my
partner um because I'm offended that him
and his sister do not like like the
lenium floors or whatever it is like I
need help and it's honestly it's not
about this if you're refusing to come to
Christmas it's not about this it's some
it's a bigger drama this person is a
drama queen and this person has like
must have a problem with like feeling
disrespect respected or something and
then you're going to people like that
that are afraid they're being
disrespected all the time always find
they're a magnet to examples of feeling
disrespected and obviously looking for
it it's like it's like if I like it's
like for instance if I want to go like
look at my Reddit page or something and
then there's something like that's on me
like I know that I'm going to read those
comments or like I'm choosing that like
I can't be mad that it exists correct
like this morning I woke up and I was
like you know I'll check one hidden
message checked it and the message the
message said you ugly rat and I was like
close and I was like oop this is I
deserve that I deserve that stab this
morning because I you take
responsibility yes if you're looking to
find something guess what you will but
also it sounds like it's going to be a
way better Christmas without this [__]
I know I was just going to say that also
when people do those like that's her
boundary for herself that's not yours so
just ignore her okay imagine what you
want to miss Christmas you miss
Christmas imagine that apology let's
play it out okay you're who I you're the
girl and I have to apolog um Esther um I
just want to say I really want you to
come over for Christmas and I'm so sorry
that I said something about your
backsplash like I just think it's a
little dated and um I don't love the
color you chose and I'm really sorry
will you please come to Christmas thank
you for apologizing because that was so
rude when I was spying on you on my pet
camera and I overheard your conversation
that I was specifically looking to over
here cuz I know you hate me and I know
you guys don't like me and I was looking
for trouble and I'm using this as an
excuse to not come to your family
Christmas also they're pet sitting
they're already doing you a favor
they're already doing you a favor it's
like crazy it's so annoying and also
it's like if you think they were talking
[__] on you then imagine how much
they're talking [__] on you now you're
getting globally talk [__] on okay now
look what you did Lady hello slugs from
Australia spread this around tell
everyone what a [__] this lady is if we
were to talk to this woman with
compassion I think we would say like
there's some work to do here
for Tuesday don't spy on people and like
I don't know what else would we say I
say home decor is not something that
it's it's so subjective like it's like
and it's not it doesn't [__] matter
dude I just had my this summer I had my
office like redesigned I like in
invested in it like it was a huge deal
my mom comes she's like this is what
this is what it is you paid for this
just fully rude trashing it and I'm like
I want to kill her but then I was like
you know what it's great that my mom
doesn't like you don't want your mom to
like this yeah this is great she also
might have just been thinking about you
spending money yeah do you know what I
mean it might have had nothing to do
what it looks like but I also I think
it's both I think she genuinely doesn't
like it and I'm like okay if my mom
liked everything I did I would not be
here you would not be here I would have
a very normal very regular life yeah I
agree okay the next one okay my best
friend's wife is thinking of leaving for
a gay man but she doesn't know he's gay
oh my God my best friend's wife is
thinking of leaving for a gay man but
she doesn't know he's gay so she okay
wait so who so if my let yeah let's
suppose um you're you're you want to
leave Todd is it that the doctor is a
woman a guy right yeah you want to leave
Todd for someone else but you don't know
that someone else is gay and know what
do we do but why is it it's it's his
best friend's wife so why does he know
that his best friends yeah that's
confusing that's weird are you the gay
guy probably um no the best friend
probably confided in him like Hey my
wife wants to leave me oh and knows who
but wouldn't would he already know that
part I think it might be over when she
says I'm going to leave you for someone
else I think maybe that's this would be
like if we heard a rumor that Tod Todd
was leaving Annie for someone who was
gay yeah it would be the same as Todd we
okay so Todd decides to leave you for a
chick it's not real okay we're just I've
already I've processed it she F so and
then we I'm here he is leaving you for
this girl and Esther and I are like
isn't she gay I don't think he knows
she's gay and I'm like and Esther and I
are like no we I know for sure she's not
even by she's fully gay and she doesn't
like men this sucks this is layered yeah
okay I think you okay hold on let's move
on to a different one I don't know who
they're talking to though so it's like I
need to a frame of reference of like so
they're asking like the confusing part
is that it's his best friend but I think
what it is is it's saying my wife is
thinking of leaving for a gay man that I
know is gay but she doesn't what about
my friend think of leaving her
relationship for someone that's gay what
do you do tell them they're gay you go
that person's gay I know they're gay
they're gay but also kind of just like
again let them choose their own
adventure also leave your but also leave
your I would say if you want to leave
someone leave them if that's your choice
to leave and you but if you're leaving
for another person and someone knows
they're gay I mean that might be a nice
does that person not reciprocated yet
well whether or not she knows he's gay
is she wants to leave anyways right so
it doesn't matter if the guy's gay
genuinely 100% gay then he's not he
hasn't reciprocated with her yet so
she's leaving on a chance anyway so let
her leave on the chance it could be like
one of those genen Z gays where they're
like they like everybody I like
information though do it's like I would
rather have like Todd never like allows
secrets for me like someone tried to
throw me a surprise party and he told me
immediately it's like I don't mind that
I don't mind if someone tells me like a
fact they know about someone when I'm
about to I'm about to enter into
something if you're entering into enter
I'm not there yet so it's like yeah
before I go in that'd be great I just
found out my dad's wife was cheating on
him their entire marriage she died three
years ago that's the juicy gossip you
leave it yeah I think you leave it let
him let him go with the the joy of the
memory and by the way she pulled it off
what a g congratulations that's how I
always felt like if people are cheating
on me and I don't find out God bless you
unless the guy who she was unless the
guy who she was cheating with killed her
that would not and
that's like a poison and then and then
his dad is like spending the last years
of his life trying to find out who K his
wife oh now we're just writing a movie
well we could always exume her body
should we raise money yes guys send it
to our cash up we'll get to it
eventually think you leave this as it is
and you just talk to your therapist
about it and let your dad have peace I
think so too I think so I don't think
there is any point in um like
imagine how horrible he would feel if he
thought his entire marriage was a lie I
have just a follow-up question what if
she was like he's really hung up on her
and she was like an awful person and no
you still would she's gone there's no
you don't there's no outcome that needs
to you bury it he could just live his
whole life not feeling betrayed you bury
it oh yeah so we're can we're going do a
little try a little segment called show
me your tabs we could do like the most
unhinged text you sent or got this week
um the most unhinged text I sent was to
a friend and it says I'm obsessed with
Chris Christie's body what that's what
it said I texted Tim Dylan I said
Hollywood is so gay I my my last
screenshot is I was I took a screenshot
of my skims order this morning and sent
it to my friend roomie and I got the new
boyfriend collection I'm a little
disrespected I always send you my screen
grabs of skims do you I got the whole
new oh I did see that I thought I
responded to that wait how has it cute
it's pretty cute yeah I got I this is
actually pretty unhinged for me um I
sent my agent a text that said I liked
our talk yesterday I've never I've never
enjoyed a talk with him before so this
is big um I have one from my lovely ex
that says I have a lump in my armpit I
think it's armpit cancer don't worry and
I said oh I have an appointment with Dr
K want to come with me he goes is he an
armpit doctor I said he's an everything
doctor dingdong he goes okay I haven't
seen him in so long I love him I love
him he's amazing same doctor I have no
unhinge texts because you're pregnant
yeah they're just about like that part
of my life is like expired I'm looking
up requirements to become a boat captain
that's unhinged that's unhinged Captain
can we talk also about the Chris
Christie thing like are you quitting
like just a boat captain no it's just a
license so that I can take you guys on a
boat that's can I drive you around to
Catalina put this on us like you want to
hang out with us don't do that don't
play us jump in guys you're leaving us
also
the Chris Christie thing is I think I U
my TV was on and I saw a shot of him
walking from spot a to spot B and I was
like oh my God like that is such he has
a very unique shape to him and like I
don't know how his legs hold him up but
I really like his body it's I was he
literally has a FAA he has it
a body it's very Humpty Dumpty it's very
round it's very cute but it's so cute me
no it's he's got a like B C he's got a
front and back Bonk he's got booty he's
got 360 booty I like that I meant it I I
I mean I meant it when I said it I
wasn't even trying to troll I was like I
really like it I sent my um my friend I
Google imaged Jan sutan my um my raler
and to show my friend and he's so cute
look at him
cing I always think of froling which is
just frisbee
golfing that's so
funny does Dave of frolf no but we had
that in high school it kind of is a
fraling of massage where it's like they
do like it's like a planned out like
series of them my guy and I do it a
little bit differently but it's like
it's like they it's like a restructuring
I always say it wrong it's like a
restructuring of like the fascia so that
um your bones are in the place that they
were like originally supposed to be he
also just teaches me a lot he's kind of
like a teacher and he like just teaches
me different things about my I was
having a problem with like the upper
inside of my Arch and he was like that's
the back of your knee and it's changed
my life I just keep stretching the back
of my knee that's awesome I'm loving
this Wellness Journey that you're having
right now which I've been on it the
whole time I'm just on of zic so I know
how to I can explain it did I tell you
guys that I think I got jumped at
um at my last massage so I looked up is
this new massage place that I wanted to
go to and some and I looked at reviews
cuz I always look at which massuse to to
try and everyone was like this guy is
the best and um it's going to seem at
first like it's a terrible massage but
then the next day you'll realize that oh
he healed me so I was like oh I'm down
for that experience I'm telling you like
I thought he like I thought I was in a
kumate like I thought I was in a
full-blown [__] likeon he beat me the
up and I'm I'm used to deep tissue I'm
used to everything this guy was angry he
was angry that I was taking too long to
take my necklaces off and like I thought
like cracked my orbital bone you taking
I had a fuing bruise on the side of my
face no her face is her money I know I
love this I want to be beaten inage then
here's what I this is why it comes back
full circle is it you there was a part
of me that wanted to make the
appointment again this week with the
same guy is he old he is older he's very
strong and he's very abusive and he so
mean and he is it ACU pressure does he
have a missing F far and he I I sent you
my acup pressure guy he'll [__] you up
[__] really it's not even [__] you up I
like being [__] up in all the right
ways no like he punched me up like he
like he decked me a couple times like
you reminded him of someone and then so
I told my sister I was like that was
like horrible that was painful and then
a couple days later I was like hey can
you look me massaged with Sam
you K cuz you want to see if you're
wrong I know yes I want to know if I'm
wrong about also this is why your red
moon got killed so many times this is
why you keep going back into [__] no I
said I'm with you go check it out again
and then see what's up you just survived
but I have a the Kung Fu acupressure his
main claim to fame is that he saved
Scott beo from back surgery but did he
save Scott beo from Scott Bao he cannot
no one can do that no one can do that um
but he's really amazing have you guys
ever gone these places I feel like have
been popping up all over La the last
like five years have you ever gone to
like a stretch Place yeah where they'll
stretch your body for you never but I
have seen them that's like I used to do
that whenever I was like shooting a show
I would do that on the weekends and I
feel like that was really great did you
do it also working out or did you do it
like in place of working out cuz I've
done that before I don't know I've don't
remember and is it still worth doing
both times I think it's very satisfying
and helpful when I don't feel when I'm
sore from working out but it's also
because I'm like I have like a block on
foam rolling it's like basically like I
don't want to do it myself so foam
rolling is hard it's clunky it's just
I'm on the floor there's dog hair on me
I want it to be easier it's really we I
want it done to me I like it and as you
guys know I broke my pinky toe on a foam
roller oh your arch nemesis I'm so sorry
I should trigger warning I should said
that I saw on your IG story that you
went to uh a scalp massage place I did
did you go to one in um San Gabriel yes
I drove to San Gabriel yeah I know that
one tell me is that the one that the
Kardashian I didn't know that until I
got there and saw pictures of them my
hair looked so good is that what it's
for what is it for I don't I don't know
cuz I didn't okay I did not go what was
the reason I did not go for like good
hair cuz I don't care about hair
whatever basically cocky she has good
hair she just has good hair I do have
good hair I'll give myself that credit
it's really it's a little greasy smells
bad but it's fine yes it's often dirty
um but pregnancy has dried my hair out
which I think means I have a vitamin
deficiency and it's not good but but you
just have regular hair now you just know
what it's like have to wash it I could
go okay so this scalp place I've been
seeing on Tik Tok and finally I'm like
I'm going I booked a 90-minute thing I
think it was like 130 bucks plus tip and
basically like you get there they do a
zoom camera of your roots which I could
have done without it's very scary in
there they're like this is dry what's
moving around in there
it's there's a slug like trust me when I
tell you you do not want to see your
scalp up close it's horrifying but then
then you lay down they put you in like a
bed that is a massager which I actually
didn't like that I don't know if it's a
pregnancy whatever so I didn't do that
part but then they wash your hair scrub
your scalp for like an hour it wasn't as
it wasn't it was fine then they put like
they rinse your hair with this rinsing
machine they wash it really good like
you get [__] squeaky clean then you
come out and they like comb your hair
with this like vibrating comb and like
they do all this stuff do they then like
sell the comb or you keep going you can
buy those Combs though they're not up
there was no upselling though which I
appreciated they were not trying to get
me to buy anything else and so just
basically you go in 90 minutes someone's
like messing with your hair and it's
great I think I recommend it but I also
think this version of me pregnant I'd
rather get a massage it's you kind of
have to go like I would totally all
three go like I would go we need a mass
with three hands one of the things that
puts me to sleep is I anyone like
playing with my hair or I love the
sensation of like scalp scrubbing my mom
loves to pick scalps like my brother had
like this is like my mom's weird thing
my brother had like a little like crusty
scalp when he was little and she loved
picking it I just remember picking I
like that too I wish that dry bar would
just offer like a really good shampoo I
got done Dirty by dry bar once and I
haven't dry bar sucks dry bar gave me
like like a Jerry curl I was like waa I
said like the beach wve bit like I was
like I look like culturally
appropriation like I'm culturally
appropriating with this spray tan I'd be
very careful what I do like this is
already Puerto Rican for the weekend
like I got to be careful I have never
had a good experience at dry bar and I'm
so mad about it cuz it's like in the
such perfect thing in theory it should
have taken the need for me to ever bathe
again and it has not done that though
the bathing still doesn't happen no wait
have you done like a scalp Spa thing um
I've never but I know that I've seen
that all over Tik Tok recently did did
you know that existed before is that for
hair growth no I only knew I don't know
I'm doing still on I'm on the pikme
level I'm still doing like what are the
strongest men doing what are the richest
strongest men doing and I'll do anything
I see like H girls on Tik Tok gen Z girl
I'm like I'm going to live to 110 no and
I'm like I'm going to be beautiful and
pretty I'm going to be a little baby
forever so I'm in San Gabriel a lot
because Asian and best Asian food go get
Vietnamese food
best will you just yeah yeah yeah you
want to go on field trip all of the best
restaurants are in sgv like count down
it's not that far but I always see the
massage place and I'm always like hm I
saw it before it even blew up so I'm
like huh like I wonder what that is but
like you know it's like Korean skincare
like is is it Korean I I'm not sure it's
Korean but they're they're just ahead of
the game right with so many things like
that should be the name of it if it's an
Asian place that called ahead of the
game like if I ever go back to Japan
which I need to do I want to research
all the the spots like that and go hard
she wants to go back this is huge I've
been wanting to go to Japan I want to go
you changed you became a different
person I think I when I went to Italy
last summer I sort of Saw and then also
again suffering of pregnancy of course
right when you're pregnant and you can't
travel anymore and then you're going to
have a kid like take over your life
that's when I want to see the world like
great than now memor of Dave's going to
be pushing both of you in
scrollers a that is cute have you guys
gotten lymphatic like drain massages um
I think a while ago yes my friend you
know Bianca at The Comedy Store who's
like the hottest [__] alive yes she
gets them and her body's like I mean
it's like crazy like I'm sure she
already has a good body but she like
swear by she goes to like the the Korean
Spas I think and gets them she gets like
she's like I am getting like they beat
her up though it's like this guy Sam I'm
fine with being beat up but beat up
correctly is you different the Kung
being punched in the face R I love this
conversation I think this is so perfect
for like end of year cuz that is the
time where I'm like I'm going to you
know it's been a it's been a year let's
invest do a little self-care go to the
scalp Spa get a lymphatic whatever you
know wait you know what my like we've
probably talked about this year already
but like I think the most Innovative spa
treatment the future of spa treatment
basically the biggest innovation in the
last can I guess 50 years what yeah when
they pull and stretch you to be
taller one person pulls your head and
the other one pulls the legs you're
triggering me cuz when I was little my
dad said you could go in a stretching
machine if you want to be taller and
then I thought that was real and found
out it wasn't it was just in China oh
they can also just break your legs girl
yeah there's a whole system and you're
going to look very disproportionate it's
just not FDA approved okay you're going
to you're probably going to be like no
that's not not that big of a deal cuz
you've known about it for a while I
think Buckle face massage is the most
important you it's hard to find places
that do it it's very new it's like very
invasive it's if you don't know it's
like when they put gloves on they
[__] go in your mouth it's like for
your jaw too they like go in jaw up the
thing so stranger's hand is now in your
mouth it's very violating but I think
that's like the future of spa I think
that's the most important spa treatment
to get and also they find like like my
girl that does it she like finds like
knots in my cheek like there's like
knots inside your cheek I feel that and
it's not enjoyable not to Hype up the
the boy I'm with but one of the perks is
that he gives the best facial massages
with his penis he sh his mouth and then
he like now I just plop like if we're
watching TV I'll go in front of him and
he already knows that I he'll it's so he
hits all the spots cuz he has bad TMJ
but he also just is like a Healer type
he knows massages he knows body like
Anatomy I've never been the steal your
boyfriend type until right now I he is
just a [__] best with the massages
and I'm just there like every night he
does this for me and like when I'm not
with him I'm like [__] like I can feel
my jaws like tensing up that's all I
care about now it's like I will stay
with him forever just for that yeah Todd
gives me massages too it's the best like
when I had my cluster headaches it's
like I don't know what I it's just I
can't even believe I had to go through
them with the boyfriends I had before he
just like I mean he saved my life he
what does he do he just like massages
like the pain area and it's like it
doesn't like it helps it a little it
doesn't get rid of them but it's like
it's just anything you know it's just
that's why I love my raler so much when
I had my cluster headaches I would like
go to him and he was he has such like a
deep sorrow that he couldn't like solve
it for me but it was like I always like
tell him it's like just the fact that
you were like a witness to the pain and
were able to like teach me at least like
the connection between the different
like pain points it was like why I have
that too if I need my suffering to be
witnessed sh I think it's something
people don't like believe too it's like
a weird thing people don't understand
like when Dave was there when I had my
first vomit from the pregnancy I was
just like that helped yeah he saw that
he saw how bad that was that really
helped well cuz sometimes it's almost
like I don't want to be like
exaggerating I mean obviously the CLS
are different but it's like it's hard to
be like this was so bad yeah like it's
already over to you're fine now right so
yeah it's I think you're absolutely on
to something there like it's like
they're not able to understand the
gravity of what you're going through
until they're there in the room with you
and that feels so you feel so seen and
invalidated I'm like why is that good I
don't know but I like which is why I've
changed my mind back in the day I used
to think that um if I were to ever
vaginally give birth that I wouldn't
want my husband to see the baby um
coming out coming out but now I'm like
no no no he he has to see what my body
has gone through he absolutely has to
see if I have whatever type of tears I
have he has to see it mhm I don't agree
and I've thought about this anyone that
wants to watch my baby come out of me
however it's coming out are you speaking
to them
now go to sign.com
no I think that's I that's too violating
come on it's his baby it's my Gina
ripping up but he his penis put the
sperm in you it's his baby that's
nothing eser I completely agree but also
he would Dave if if you had a paper cut
he would faint so I'm fine he's not
going to do it okay yeah yeah yeah but
would you let someone watch that course
you would yeah it depends what kind of
guy I'm with if it was like a Bobby not
not a chance in hell he would be like or
vagina for like the next 10 episodes
he'd be like oh you could have should
have seen the way [__] you know but if
it was with somebody has to be a certain
type who can like look at it and be like
wow this is actually incredible like
it's type of guy that is okay with that
stuff I think it depends it's a case by
case thing listen if a if the baby you
put in me that's our baby comes out and
you're grossed out by it like we have
way bigger problems but I'm not thinking
that they'd be grossed out I'm grossed
out she but what she was I was because
back in the day I used to think like I
just was like I don't want
so I heard a story that when Elvis
Presley saw Priscilla give birth he
never wanted to have sex with her again
he's a Madonna wh guy that's yeah so
like that somehow stuck into my young
[__] 20-some head and I was like oh
you're never going to see my vagina
other than its like pristine condition
and I'm like actually no you should you
probably [__] should there are lasers
it's fine yeah it snaps back just fine
no everyone I've talked to is like it's
don't worry yeah yeah it's fine that's
I'm not concerned I'm so glad that's
what you said I like like afraid you
were going to say the episod nothing
works no people are like it's not what
you think and the baby's head shrinks on
its way out and your body does what I
needs to do I'm not concerned about the
vanity of it at all but the terror and
Trauma of it is I'm very scared about
yeah but I don't have to think about
that for a really long time but I think
your your body does a really good job or
your brain does a good job of protecting
yourself because this is why like women
have two three kids CU my friends who
have more kids are like you kind of just
forget you have this amnesia happen and
you don't remember the pain of Labor
until you have a second kit and then you
have a third one so I'm like that's a
weird thing that you're that imagine
three what if you change and you're
become like you have like seven kids
yeah I know I wouldn't I wouldn't that
out no I know who but it's crazy you're
from a family of three that's crazy my
mom was real pissed about it she really
want twins that's CRA honestly all of my
core wounds are cuz my like my mom was
pissed there was two I and I feel for
her she got two when she wanted one and
when you already had one you're not
going to just assume her mom died when
she was pregnant with she was probably
so pissed she's like the [__] timing
of that I also like I know twins are
like a magical beautiful thing for sure
but I also thank you waiting for you to
say it on that um no just vaginal
tearing no yes the teror of
tearing and would you guys comment below
like subscribe comment click the Bell
let us know if you are a boy slug if you
want to watch that tear and ladies if
you want to spread that VZ hole and and
show everyone I also would love to know
if people have like real insightful
thoughts just even in the comments like
cuz we've talked about some big things
this this episode like you know me
wanting to intervene in relationships
that I don't approve of and like you
going back to a person who hurt you and
what's that like if you guys have
thoughtful feelings about that share
because and if you have a shared love
for Chris Christie's body please like
write me and if if you have any comments
on my semi glutide use you can keep
those tears off I'm I'm vibrating too
high to see you by the way I just want
to say something about that thank you
for actually saying it out loud I am so
sick and tired I will be completely
honest with you guys and I also want to
be very clear I have no interest in
being very thin so if the minute that
starts happening it's gone and I don't
believe in the shortage I'm so sorry you
can come up with any statistics you want
a very simple thing for me to do and
maybe don't get the name brand with the
clicker thing and just get the thing
from the yeah you could just get
straight and so I don't care what you
think but if I can Inspire some people
to think to see that maybe there's some
other benefits to it but I'll be honest
with whatever happens in the future most
importantly happy freaking New Year you
guys we will not be seeing you until
next week which is literally next year
have extremely safe New Year's EES okay
stay home with Mom and Dad pop open a
book book have an eser pop open a book I
won't allow you to say that next to me
do not pop open a by the way my friend
wrote a book about running and he gave
it to me I was like oh cool two things I
don't do running and reading thanks dude
throw this in the trash but you guys
please have safe New Year's EES take
Ubers don't get too drunk you know what
to
do don't but live geted up have fun
safely we love you and we want to see
you next week with a brand new episode
in
2024 we love you guys enjoy your
flowers that was really
[Music]
wholesome